[Music]
if you guys are interested in probably
one of the coolest uh rabbit holes of
content right now there's this uh person
named terolyn Romero and on Tik Tok uh
she's her name is the real Wicked Witch
of the West and that's a long ass handle
yeah she's going through this insanely
detailed legal dispute over this house
that she bought in Colorado and um
you're going to love this story because
it's it is really messed up what the
government's trying to do with her land
that she rightfully bought so here's how
it starts she buys this house in
Jefferson County it's in a uh the city
of kidge uh Colorado and in this house
it's like on a hill and it's advertised
as having like ooh a creek runs through
your backyard that's beautiful yeah so
it's not even a full acre but then down
the backyard there's like a whole Creek
going through it's it really is
beautiful so she buys this home and then
uh as the seasons change and it starts
to get like warmer all of a sudden she
just sees hell of people using the creek
like as if it's a public park but this
is her actual yeah that's my house prop
she pays taxes on this right so then she
goes back there and she starts filming
these people they're like having full-on
parties picnics you know they'll leave
their trash there they'll like dig up
the ground and like you know just random
stuff that you would do at like a little
beach and then she starts you know
trying to reason with them like hey like
I bought this house right here this is
technically my land can you guys like
please you know respect it whatever the
[__] out yeah she's actually like
initially pretty decent about it but
then the neighborhood starts to Rally
against her is it cuz they've been doing
that for like hella years and then
they're like oh well how you [__]
California ass moving over here trying
to tell us how to [__] I don't know
if she's from California but from the
West happens right like people hate
California cuz they move all over to
other states and then they do this whole
like not in my backyard yeah Manifest
Destiny Yeah so basically it becomes it
it like turns into this huge tiate of
like hatred from the people in the town
and they start having these like
meetings and Town Hall things where
they're like saying that she should get
the land taken away from her and stuff
oh that's and then the actual County
ends up uh filing a suit against her and
trying to claim the land through adverse
possession which is one of those like
weird statutes that kind of says oh
somebody's been or or like the last
person who owned this land and the last
person who owned it before them has
always let it happen it's been this way
for 35 years so we're going to take this
land what oh makes sense it's crazy and
so uh so she's every step of the way
from the very start she's documented all
of this on the Tik Tok she's very like
transparent about like here's the
paperwork that we file here's what they
said um and then so the Count's also
telling her like at this point they're
like yeah we there's been no objections
to how the land is used for 35 years and
um and they're saying that uh in the
mean time you can have all the time you
want to prepare your legal defense but
uh during this time you have to open
your land to the public what yeah
they're telling they were telling her
that and then also they said that the
the creek is actually owned by the uh
County but that over time the creek
moved and because the creek moved they
should still own the creek the
government is dumb as [__]
wow that's the craziest [__] that's
something called accretion it's like
when a body of water or like something
like it's always changing yeah it's
always changing yeah but they're saying
like oh we we you know you own the land
but the creek which runs through it used
to run here and now it's through your
land that means the Creek's now yours I
owned this the Creek from here to here
[__] I don't say I own the whole Creek
you own that [__] I'm not saying that
you know when you buy a house they give
you the [__] Deed there's [__]
like coordinates and [__] and it goes
this is what you own yeah so they ended
up reaching a settlement where she she
offered to sell them back a portion of
the land she's like all right you guys
can't take it but I will I'm willing to
sell you part of it so then that's smart
they stop throwing Chick-fil-A rappers
everywhere I know yeah north side of the
creek though I own the south side it has
that land does get pretty like trashed
and so um she ends up reaching that
settlement where they're going to uh
they're like trying to figure out like
draw the lines and everything and it's
still continually getting messy every
step of the way they're always trying to
like put one over on her like even when
they draw the lines or even when they go
there and they physically place the
poles to be like here to here it's
different the next time it's like
there's all these like little snags and
then so what she ends up
doing is she files a demand letter to
the previous owner who sold her the home
to be like you didn't disclose any of
this when you sold the home you actually
listed it as um on the advertisement for
the sale it says wow Bear Creek running
through the backyard wow yeah that's on
the Zillow yeah and then so um you're
not allowed to do that you can't just be
like oh and then and then later on be
like oh actually that's a disputed land
because they never disclosed that the
entire top half of the land was under
adverse Claim by the county and then
during the deposition that they had with
the legal teams the previous owners
actually did say oh we always thought
the creek was part of the
park so you can't say that is part of
the park and advertise the house sale
like oh you get this Creek so um there's
even a recorded phone call with the
prior owners where they said um they're
recorded saying they didn't want the
public to know that they own that land
because sorting the ownership was going
to be a major undertaking and that they
knew there would be a resident Uprising
who if they brought it up so they just
let people use it
oh so then she's sending a demand letter
for I think 1 Point 2 mil 1.6 mil
something like that like a lot to F the
damages she's had like a horrible time
like people have been yeah they treated
her like total [__] yeah she sounds like
a Karen to be honest like I kind of
blame her why I think she doesn't know
how to mediate I I think she doesn't
know how to negotiate I think this whole
thing between her and the city it
escalates because well depending on how
you approach people I don't know how she
talked to them or whatever right but
they're both the city and her are
fighting about the stupidest [__]
because this is the main reason the the
way the reason why it was a nuisance is
because the people were [__] digging
up [__] and leaving trash right so I
tell the city yeah sure if it's owned by
you guys why don't you enforce that
people don't come to the [__] nature
and destroy the [__] out of it and then
I'm like okay well where's your get some
Park Rangers get some bathrooms get some
things like make it make it a good spot
where people can enjoy but still act
[__] civil mhm cuzz I think that's
the biggest issue is like it's like some
people don't know how to like respect a
land and then they feel entitled to it
but then they [__] it up hard yeah what
they listen though you know like Eden
Canyon has [__] tons of graffiti I'm
sure there people complain about it but
I feel like it depends on the the
community's culture and then everything
right cuz like you will go to certain
places and there's [__] beer cans
everywhere and destroyed and you'll go
to other places and people know how to
[__] act civil and enjoy nature and
pick up after themselves so I'm
like Hawaii you know like there's a lot
of places like the graffiti is kind of
sick though it's a nice touch Utah
Utah's a good example what about the
idea that it's her land she pays taxes
and she doesn't want to have to share it
with people and she doesn't want to be
forced to do that uh yeah plus she's
probably liable if something happens in
the property whole thing start a fire
like something like she's liable for the
you know situation which is why the
government's probably like okay fine
we'll take it back so then if they do
take it I think she is entitled to
payment or compensation for them they
can't just sees it I think that's what's
[__] up not she does Come Away with
like a million dollar I'll you here's a
visual this is what the land looks like
started to warm up everything changed
beautiful as [__] people started
wandering into my
backyard Park that sits next to my
backyard know by the summer I had 55
people
wandering into my backyard almost every
single day and it had become a
full-blown water park I was incredibly
confused I just bought this property I
did all the due diligence well you did
do the that that is mine why are so many
people coming here it's my backyard I'm
paying taxes on it I own all of it and
they were destroying it they broke my
trees they destroyed the creek Bank
they left
trash and they were there all the time
you I can hear them in my house they're
just right outside my window so I went
down and talked to everybody to figure
out what in the world was going on some
people knew that the property was
Private some people said prior owners
gave us permission to be back here many
years ago and other people had no idea I
figured I've just got to make people
aware that this is private property said
I just moved
you know this is my backyard in that
first year I didn't tell anyone to leave
I don't know I think there's the legal
part but I also think there's
the whole like dude this is your
newcomer like yeah why don't you get
with the community program and then
blend in and then make your changes yeah
but bro they're making a Hurricane
Harbor in her backyard it's like it's
it's this is not the same thing well
what about the too like why can't that's
what I was thinking why can't there be
fences and signs and like you know she
did she ended up putting signs and
roping it off and they people just
didn't give a [__] they're flipping her
off from the from from her backyard
at well can she start shooting them then
cuz that's kind of nice I start shooting
them stole the land and it was just a
nightmare they do look indigenous it
that's what it sounds like it sounds
like Native Americans indigenous whites
of Colorado yeah this is our land funny
would talk to a grand with her young
yeah they pretty much like always flip
her off and they like harass her I would
go to war I yeah I think the uh the
[__] up person is the s for
trespassing I think it's illegal to
shoot people so you want her to share
the land and shoot them I would say hey
this is my
land come use mediate and shoot him but
if you if you flip me off yeah you're
trespassing he said he said they weren't
civil W civil and he's like start open
fire but civil or not it's like I think
she's so her angle is that she knows her
rights and she's just like I don't have
to do anything like this is just my land
and the fact that the government's
trying to like push these like things on
her unfairly she's just trying to fight
back against the government for you know
just the good of the
law I think um she might have a case
against her like title or the people
that went through escrow cuz in due
diligence that that's the part where
you're supposed to go uh was anything
still unsettled like are there any leans
like any other prior um yeah like
litigation going through and then
there's that whole adverse like land
thing right where like they've been
arguing over it like that stuff should
have came up yeah she has a video
explaining why she's not suing them oh
really and she she B it during offseason
right like it was winter time or some
[__] and then all wouldn't she just be
like okay so I have my own
Creek no they really made her think they
really made her think like in every way
like all the verbiage was like
yeah yeah it was a selling point yeah
they didn't say anything about the land
dispute about the usage about she did
say wow though say wow wow this Creek
she should have ran into the wow her
name her name Tern does rhyme with Karen
I think she needs to create a Sniper
Tower yeah to mediate from
I like where you're going now and I need
she needs a sign that says no
trespassing no
trespassing violators will be shot damn
shot on site you don't think that's
going to create a little more friction
with the town nah no no no no and and
then on the bottom don't test it civil
this is and on the bottom it's please
sign up for for a water park
pass see that would be yeah and then
it's like I got a water water pack park
pass and then it's like all right cool
you could come in oh my God yeah she's
got just sell admission and then as soon
as somebody comes in the water park they
get blown up by an ID and then and then
Joe's like all
right those all those explosives oh [__]
and then next time you just puts play at
your own risk at an ass risk there are L
landmines out here landmines question
mark dealing with people is tough cuz
then like this is like a pretty extreme
case but then you also even hear like of
neighbors just fighting for that one
inch of where the property L they put up
Hedges and I can't [__] see or this
is part of mine and they're fighting
literally for like this much of land and
they're just trying to shift it you got
to go to court for that and [__] because
over time you know like the creek it
just moves the house you got to put your
[__] foot down put some landmines in
there isn't the creek big isn't there
other spots they can go [__] hang out
at well I guess because like this every
couple
years moving especially all these
[__] digging at the side of it
they're redirecting the flow of water
yeah breaking trees that's what I would
do if I was a commun I would start
moving the creek back right that's kind
of sick the way that the geography looks
it looks like there's like a like a like
a state park right there and then you
can see that little creek Bank from the
park so it looks very OB like I think
like intuitively you'd go oh let's go
over there you know what I mean there
are other parts of the creek but it's
such an accessible like I guess
traditionally you just go there all the
time yeah they just go all the time and
beautiful though it looks great and she
paid a lot of money for the you know the
property a nice fence I feel like could
solve this problem but no I think so I
think that's where they are now I
believe that they now that she you know
is selling them back some of the land I
believe that they're dividing you know
but then I don't know if they want to
put a fence I think she's saying the um
maybe the county will put a fence but to
put a fence just kind of that's also
weird yeah I honestly think they just
need to pay her but the space needs to
be public you know what I mean they just
need to buy it from her at yeah that's
what she's saying she's like it's fine
just like it's mine so they can't just
do I think that's
yeah and then it's official moving
forward for every future owner and then
sniper towers and IED sniper to towers
are the best with trip wire trip wire is
really good the city should pay for this
Sniper
Tower
no